somebody said if you want to lose
something lose money regret is the thing
that I fear the most
who is that tonight and I ain't wasting
any time I got a list of stuff I want to
try I want to make sure that this set
makes me better rise and shine it's
expresso time good morning believe
nation it seven my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
an amazing gift inside you that I want
to see exploded on to the world so grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
don't lose time over to you Les Brown is
there anything that you wish you didn't
do yes I wish I had not waited 14 years
somebody said if you want to lose
something lose money you can get that
back eight out of ten millionaires have
been financially bankrupt Walt Disney
filed bankruptcy seven times that too
nervous breakdowns but don't lose time
there were fourteen years I said on the
sideline 14 years I said I don't have an
investor in me like Tony Robbins 14
years that said I don't have an MBA or a
PhD and and I can't compete with these
guys I have the complexion of rejection
14 years I silenced mice Wow and so I
regret that because there are some
people that maybe if they'd heard my
voice they would not have turned to
drugs if they'd heard my voice their
lives would have taken a different
direction and I can't get those 14 years
back that haunts me and me I think that
drives me when I speak with such energy
I'm trying to make up for that time hmm
but I can regret is the thing that I
fear the most the idea that I could have
done more that I could have been more
that I could have pushed harder that I
could have had a bigger impact is the
thing that fuels me the most in my life
in my business in both a business
context for
accomplishments I could have done or
making better videos for you guys and
reaching the wider audience but also my
personal life and being a better father
and being a better husband and being a
better son it's constantly the drive
that I don't want to be 95 years old
looking back on my life and thinking I
could have done more I could have been
better and this really started for me
when I was in Paris when I was 18 ish
and I was on a summer break there and I
had a map and I was standing us at the
Notre Dame Cathedral and this girl comes
up to me and she wants to ask me for
directions and I'm thinking whom does
she really want asking for directions
and what I wanted to do was ask her out
and I'm wondering why she asked me
directions in French like her French is
perfect you should know where she's
going like something else is going on
here but I chickened out I was too
afraid I didn't ask her out I didn't ask
her to you know coffee or anything else
and I felt so bad about myself she
laughed I took a picture of the area and
when I went home I put it up on my wall
and it was a constant daily reminder for
me whenever I woke up I'd see that
picture whenever I walked into the room
I would see that picture the reminder
for me was not to live with regret
because what I did was I let that
immediate fear of rejection of failure
be stronger than me knowing if it was
gonna work out or not then potentially
having a great day and I tried to then
take that approach to everything that I
did in my life that if I thought I might
regret doing this thing or not doing
this thing then I knew what I had to do
I had to take action and it's feeling
the fear because that immediate fear is
real that immediate fear to ask somebody
out to take that plunge to take that
phone call to do that speech to go talk
to that customer that immediate fear is
real what I do is I make the future pain
so big that fear of regret so big that
it forces me to take action so I put
that picture on my wall as a daily
reminder for myself that the next time
something happens the next time when
opportunity comes in front of me that I
might regret not doing I have to go out
I have to take action and that actually
came for me the next year when I had an
opportunity to join this biotech
software startup company I thought I was
on the path to be a
I had potential great jobs lined up to
make 80 to $100,000 starting salary and
traveling around the world or make few
hundred bucks a month working at this
startup company and owning a piece of
the business and I looked at that
picture and it made me remember that I
don't want to live with regret then I
can handle the business not working out
I can handle starting it and trying it
and it failing but what I couldn't
handle is not knowing cuz I could always
go back and get another job if I wanted
to I didn't want to be 10 years 20 years
30 years later still thinking what if I
just tried that startup company what if
I just said yes what if I just gave it a
month or gave it six months just to see
and so the next time that you're feeling
that you might live with regret the next
time you are afraid to do something but
you know that you really should I hope
that you summoned the courage to do it
remember this video remember my talk
remember less is talk project forward
the rocking-chair test you're on your
rocking chair at age 95 looking back on
your life fast-forward it now here to
today will you regret for the rest of
your life not taking action and if the
answer is yes then you know what you
have to do now I've got a special bonus
clip for you but before getting to that
my question of the day for you is I want
to know what is one decision that has
been on your mind that you've been
afraid to take action on that you know
you will regret you know you will regret
if you don't take action on it leave it
down in the comments below and I hope
that by writing it down it'll help you
summon the courage to actually go out
and do it today thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
and joy the bonus clip and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso
espresso give me go
so when did you get to the point where
you you know struggling to get better
make a living figure out a deal with
hecklers like million things - alright
I'm good at this now I'm gonna be try to
be great at this well that I mean that
was when I saw him do that that was a
big deal
I was writing for TV then so I was a
little bit less on that yeah but I
started going back out to clubs again
and then my life changed in its own way
I had kids and I grew up also so I just
thought you know everybody grows up at a
different time
yeah I grew up when I had kids and
started really thinking about Stan when
I had kids it made a big difference for
me because when I went out to do a set
it wasn't also it wasn't a social event
it was until that point you just go to
the Comedy Cellar have a falafel at the
comedy table yet run down and do your
set bull with some comics it was a lot
of wasting time yeah and it didn't
really matter how the set was that was
just the job I'm just gonna go on and do
my time tell the same jokes maybe do one
new joke but now it's like I've got kids
and getting out of the house is a big
deal yeah to a set tonight and I ain't
wasting time I got a list of stuff I
want to try I want to make sure that
this set makes me better every I started
to think every set I do has to make me
better comic there are four things that
we can never recover in our life a stone
after it has been thrown into the valley
words after they have been spoken an
opportunity once it is missed and time
once it has gone considering the average
lifespan of a human being today to be
about 70 years 17 multiplied by 12 is
840 now that's how many months we have
in our life to live in this world and if
life is represented by a jar and those
840 months by the marbles in the jar
every year 12 marbles are being thrown
out of the charm
last year 12 marbles have gone as well
gone forever
never to come back again look at how
many marbles you now have in the jar to
make a difference to leave a mark to
stand apart
utilize your time well and your time
will treat you well leading you into an
overall sense of well-being in the new
year to come
invest in taking care of your body
invest in nurturing and nourishing your
relationships invest in finding and
discovering your purpose your passion
your calling in order to enhance your
professional growth invest in pursuing
and cultivating a meaningful deep
spiritual connect and for some reason if
you found yourself stuck in any of these
some of these or all of these areas in
the last year
the new year brings a fresh opportunity
to press the refresh button refresh the
page of your life and live well because
at the end of the day remember we are
all just stories
and make sure
is it inspiring but when you give me the
one one seat warmers one was long you
have the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
so it would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details